echt bombastisch diese spielt hallo mein
name ist khan herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video es spielen
heute battlefield 1 die leute die mich
kennen wissen dass ich sowas von scheiße
teuren bin also okay ich habe es
eigentlich auf einem kanal gebracht oder
spieler zeit ein paar tagen draußen ist
aber hey wir fangen an runde startet
sobald genügend spieler bereit sind
alles klar deger wieso keine einfach
alleine spielen damit ich doch
automatischer mein gott es geht los
freien da ihr seht schon die grafik ist
ultra geil ich zock das gerade auf einem
laptop den nvidia zugestellt hat oder
asus oder so mit einer nvidia gtx 1070
und 16 gigabyte ram und mehr das krasse
ding ist kein placement aber ich bin
einfach nur froh dass vieles ist das
video aber ich werde erste tod ich sagen
wollte ist es kein placement die leute
sind einfach nur mega cool drauf und
haben wir dieses ding ich zeige euch das
mal keine ahnung wie der heißt ich gehe
jetzt mal einfach als sturm soldaten
kampf ich weiß ich das besser kann aber
mal schauen
ich ziehe ewald um und dann habe ich ein
komplett neues setup und dann wollte ich
euch das mal zeigen in metzger hawass
getroffen
nur zwölf punkte ein schock ich bin der
viertletzte läuft bei mir gefällt euch
das wenn ich das hochladen also mehr
games ich mein ich habe mich in letzter
zeit ein bisschen mehr zum lifestyle
keine euro die im geist
ich glaube keiner will ihn sehen sein
guckt mich auch nur so anders und
behinderter spaß die alte haye
kann ich vielleicht auch mal jemand
töten hier so leute hier meine tour von
meinem zuhause man kann hier die treppe
hochlaufen ist man oben dann hat man
einen ganz schönen offenen bereich
freunde also dass wir nicht cool sind
irgendwo vielleicht auch mal gegner oh
mein gott warum immer die einfach von
hinten von vorne ins rutschen und
mittlerweile gar nichts mehr ich kenne
jetzt einfach in der ecke und bin
einfach ein paar sekunden später
wahrscheinlich von hinten wieder
ich finde dieses spiel einfach jetzt
schon so was von ziegler als cod also es
kann natürlich auch daran liegen dass
sich cod einfach übels lang nicht mehr
gespielt habe aber hey das ist also das
ist echt bombastisch dieses spiel
[Musik]
wer ohne spaß das spiel ist eigentlich
doch hallo saddam das klassische spiel
ich spüre wenn er mich jetzt wieder da
vor einsetzen der dann heule ich als ok
da vorne okay ich weiß auf jeden fall
dass da hinten dieser blöde satthaben 1
2 3 4 und der fakt mich einfach nur
appell kommt den töte ich jetzt von
hinten kommt von hinten an
wo ist der der langst bekommen glaubt
alter ich lauf hier mal ganz außen rum
damit ich wirklich nicht das risiko
eingehen dass ich von irgendwo
abgeknallt werde um mein gott da hinten
ist jemand habe ich gesehen hab ich
gesehen hab ich gesehen den werde ich
mir holen freundlich jetzt live mit
dabei irgendwo hier wird er gleich
rumkommen ich hab's im gespür team
gespürt ein gefühl für mich ein spalter
oder irre ich mich da irgendwie ein paar
sekunden später weil ich dachte ich bin
ja allein aber jetzt so viele leute von
mir was wollen die denn ich laufen mal
wieder schön außenrum meine runden und
warten mal ab ob ich irgendwo hier
diese schießen alle hinter ist doch
keiner ich weiß nicht ob das ein typ ist
oder nicht aber ich glaube er nicht
deswegen geht kann sich irgendwo hier
oben jemanden geben der da irgendwo
draußen draufsteht oder so dass mensch
laufruhig weiter kollege laufruhig
weiter laufruhig darum den hole ich mir
leute den hole ich mir ein kollege wo
bist du nicht vielleicht kann ich
schwöre euch das gegnerische team
besteht nur aus einer person stadt haben
blöder spaß wieder als sturm soldat
unterwegs weil ich glaube dass ich da
tatsächlich ein bisschen erfolgreicher
war gut ich hab bisher insgesamt zwei
clips gemacht und hier als sniper aber
hey man kann ja hoffen
ich kenne die karten übrigens noch gar
nicht ich weiß behaupten ich wo ich
irgendwie langen muss wo gegners bauen
können das ist natürlich auch ein
bisschen scheiße ich doch darum ist ein
typ mal offen hier lange hier vorne kann
ich auch wenn hier oben jetzt einer ist
dann hey
[Musik]
eine vase
eine vase ich schwöre euch es von hier
unten aus wie ein typ schaut es euch an
lager life will jemand töten oder auch
ein bisschen kopf niederlage
[Musik]
und unverdient das war es auch hier vom
video meine damen und herren wenn euch
battlefield 1 gefällt oder das video
gefallen hat dass auf jeden fall
instetten like da schreibt mal in die
kommentare battlefield 1 wenn ich das
noch mal machen soll ich weiß ja nicht
ob ich das gefällt weil ich bin halt
übel scheiße in dem game und ansonsten
würde ich sagen oh weh denn quad ist ein
komischer typ wir sehen uns im nächsten
video wieder
ich habe jetzt meine schnauze